mobilité dans les espaces peu denses en
2040 un défi à relever dès aujourd'hui
il est donc encore plus pertinent
aujourd'hui à l'aune de la crise
énergétique du retour de l'inflation
notamment des prix de carburant et de la
nécessité de réduire l'auto-solisme
monsieur rapporteur général l'amendement
1119 votre avis
c'est un avis défavorable mais l'auteur
de l'amendement c'est précisé d'ailleurs
dans l'exposé c'est un amendement
d'appel donc je vous saviez très bien
quel était l'objectif l'objectif c'est
d'appeler l'attention sur une
problématique pour laquelle aujourd'hui
je dirais on convient que de il n'y a
pas encore de solution acceptable et qui
tiennent pour pouvoir être adoptés
maintenant oui
nous allons désormais aborder une série
d'amendements qui poursuivent tous le
même objectif
augmenter le plafond du versement
mobilité que les collectivités
territoriales ont et vous le savez la
faculté d'instituer pour financer leur
transport public
pour mémoire le versement mobilité est
un impôt qui pèse sur les entreprises du
territoire dès lors quelconque plus de
16 salariés et c'est un pot est assis
sur leur masse salariale le taux de
versement mobilité est en plafonné par
la loi l'ensemble de ses amendements que
nous allons avoir examiné poursuivre
tous une même finalité relever ce
plafond pour permettre aux collectivités
territoriales qui exercent
la compétence d'autorité organisatrice
de la mobilité de disposer de davantage
de ressources pour soutenir leur service
public de transport
ces services publics essentiels sont du
fait même de la nature de leur activité
très fortement et vous le savez affecté
par la crise énergétique actuelle
je comprends donc la volonté des auteurs
de ces amendements
néanmoins et je le dis sans retenue je
suis réservé quant à la solution qu'il
préconise qui conduirait à accroître la
pression fiscale sur nos entreprises
atteignant aussi leurs compétitivité
ces entreprises qui sont elles aussi
frappées de plein fouet par la crise y
compris par la crise des énergies
je le dis je demanderai donc la vie du
gouvernement sur l'ensemble de ses
amendements afin de m'assurer que
celui-ci a pris toute la mesure de la
gravité de la situation et pour
connaître les solutions qu'il entend à
la place qui est la sienne mettre en
œuvre pour y répondre
la situation se pose avec une acuité
particulière s'agissant d'Ile de France
mobilité au vu de l'ampleur du service
public qu'il assure
vous le savez la situation de
l'établissement est critique
si l'on ne fait rien Ile de France
mobilité pourrait n'avoir d'autres choix
que de réduire son service
ce qui à l'heure actuelle au moment où
l'on prône la transition écologique dans
les transports envers ont pu en convenir
un très mauvais signal
rappelons-nous qu'en loi de finances
rectificatif pour 2020 dans le contexte
de début de crise sanitaire
des avances remboursables de l'État
avait été accordé à Île de France
mobilité
il me paraît opportun d'envisager dans
le cadre de la situation que je viens de
décrire
un report de ces remboursements et je
souhaite donc la connaître aussi la vie
du gouvernement sur la proposition que
je formule en toute état de cause et au
vu de la variété des acteurs concernés
que ce soit l'État les collectivités
territoriales les entreprises mais aussi
des usagers les solutions à mettre en
oeuvre ne peuvent pas être prises sans
l'organisation d'une vaste concertation
c'est d'autant plus problématique que
les opérateurs franciliens devront
bientôt faire face au défi de
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
proposerai mais en seconde partie un
amendement prévoyant d'insituer dès le
premier trimestre de l'année prochaine
une conférence du financement des
transports publics en Île-de-France
celles-ci pourrait être chargée de
mettre sur la table des solutions qui
permettent de soutenir efficacement
l'établissement face à la crise tout en
veillant à le soutenabilité pour les
finances de l'État comme celle des
collectivités territoriales et en
accordant une vigilance particulière à
l'enjeu de la pression fiscale que j'ai
évoquée mais aussi à celui du pouvoir
d'achat des usagers qui acquittent eux
le tarif Navigo
j'aurais tendance à
résumer ce qui arrive en disant que on
est passé finalement d'une crise de la
recette à une crise de la dépense et
bien je propose que les travaux de cette
conférence puisse être ensuite restitué
dans le cadre d'une synthèse et d'un
rapport remis par le gouvernement par le
manque au premier semestre de l'année
2023 de nature à pouvoir éclairer nos
décisions en la matière et dans la
perspective d'un éventuel et je dirais à
ce stade souhaité projet de loi de
finance rectificative sous réserve bien
sûr de son dépôt par le gouvernement
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le ministre souhaitez-vous
apporter une appréciation
prendra la parole sur les amendements
donc nous commençons par le rendement de
monsieur benaroche qui est la parole 335
que je partage totalement
concernant les versements de mobilité
mobilité entreprise on sait pas
effectivement la situation de
l'Île-de-France ce qui me permet
effectivement d'expliquer pourquoi cet
amendement cet amendement que je propose
est celui qui suit qu'un amendement de
repli qui est différent uniquement sur
les taux qui pourraient être appliqués
est un amendement qui a deux objectifs
le premier effectivement c'est de
permettre aux collectivités
territoriales hors de l'Île-de-France
d'avoir accès à un taux qui est en fait
le même que celui qui est aujourd'hui en
Île-de-France appliquée ça rétablit
effectivement à certaines équilibre ça
permet surtout dans la situation où nous
sommes de ne pas faire porter la
totalité des efforts pour développer les
transports en commun pour développer le
maillage la fréquence du territoire pas
seulement porté par l'État par les
collectivités territoriales ou par les
citoyens qui payent mais aussi
effectivement par les entreprises dans
une limite qui est celle qui est déjà
fixée pour l'Île-de-France il s'agit pas
de de demander des taux excessifs c'est
une demande qui émane en fait de
beaucoup de territoires de beaucoup de
collectivités territoriales quel que
soit d'ailleurs les majorités politiques
de ces collectivités territoriales
monsieur le rapporteur c'est une demande
qui permettra au fait dans une situation
en plus compliquée vous l'avez expliqué
par la crise de l'énergie qui fait quand
même que les citoyens qui n'ont pas de
maillage ou de réseaux de transport en
commun suffisant le subisse de plafoué
parce que bien entendu ils prennent leur
véhicule et que à ce titre là il
subissent aussi de plafouer cette crise
énergétique donc le développement et le
maillage suffisant des transports en
commun dépend aussi aujourd'hui dans
beaucoup de collectivités territoriales
des modes de financement et les
entreprises peuvent y participer au même
titre que tous les autres acteurs qui
défaitent y participent maintenant c'est
l'objet de cet abonnement je comprends
très bien la conférence monsieur le
rapporteur pour l'Île-de-France que je
laisserai
locataires mes collègues de
l'Île-de-France se prononçait là-dessus
ce que je vous demande simplement c'est
que dans les autres territoires le taux
autorisé aux différentes collectivités
soit le même que celui qui est autorisé
aujourd'hui en Île-de-France défendu
aussi l'amendement 336 c'est le même
avec des taux inférieurs qui ne
rejoignent pas ceux de l'Île-de-France
mais qui sont intermédiaire entre les
taux actuels maximum et ceux de
l'Île-de-France c'est un amendement de
repli l'amendement mille questions
monsieur ri monsieur Biak
merci monsieur le Président
je peux voir d'augmenter légèrement et
de façon temporaire les taux de version
mobilité afin de garantir des ressources
suffisantes d'organisatrices de mobilité
dès 2023 à titre d'exemple pour
l'agglomération clermontoise le prix des
énergies pour être à sport passerait de
1,8 millions en 2022 à 4,8 millions en
évidemment dans les hypothèses actuelles
du prix de gaz de l'électricité dans ce
contexte pour préserver les ressources
et bien le choix il faut une prise en
charge directe de l'État soit
l'ouverture d'avance sera remboursable
soit on relèvement temporaire du
relèvement du versement mobilité et
c'est ce qui est proposé avec une
augmentation du taux de façon limitée de
0,02 points pour l'ensemble des
catégories d'agglomération
générale donc votre avis sur les trois
premiers amendements donc 335 336 et
1400 j'ai évoqué une demande d'avis du
gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je le dis
d'emblée le gouvernement ne souhaite pas
augmenter le versement mobilité nous le
souhaitons pas parce qu'on ne peut pas
dans un même texte en tout cas tel que
nous espérons que le texte sera adopté à
la fin de la navette parlementaire à la
fois baissé d'un côté les impôts de
production massivement avec la
suppression de la CVAE et de l'autre
accepter un relèvement très substantiel
des impôts de production avec ces
augmentations proposées de versement
mobilité qui représente par exemple une
hausse à 4,5% contre 2,95% aujourd'hui
dans l'amendement qui est porté par
Monsieur Bocquet qui arrive un peu plus
tard alors j'ai bien en tête que le
Sénat est revenu je le regrette mais
revenu sur la suppression de la CVAE qui
est très attendue de notre industrie de
nos PME et de nos ETI et que donc
j'entends que il y a Dieu il y aurait du
coup si on suit cette ligne là il n'y
aurait pas d'incohérence avec une
suppression de la CVE dans le texte que
vous examinez il n'y a plus la
suppression de la CVE mais de notre
point de vue à nous qui voulons
supprimer la CVAE pour continuer à
baisser les impôts de production ça
n'aurait pas de sens de l'autre côté
d'augmenter le versement de mobilité qui
pèse sur la production et sur les
entreprises dans notre pays donc on y
est évidemment des défavorables il y a
des amendements moins dix ans on va dire
que celui de Monsieur Bocquet qui limite
la hausse à 3,27%, il représente tout de
même une hausse d'impôts de 500 millions
d'euros pour l'employeur c'est un
alourdissement du coût du travail de 130
euros chaque année pour un salarié au
double du SMIC
on peut encore moins l'accepter encore
une fois dans une partie seulement du
territoire
Île-de-France voir dans une partie
seulement de l'Île-de-France comme le
propose certains amendements ce serait
créer à notre sens des déséquilibres là
où les transports visent au contraire à
relier nos territoires c'est d'autant
plus vrai que cette impôts pèse déjà
très largement sur les entreprises
franciliennes nous sommes un certain
nombre ici à le savoir elle contribue
déjà à hauteur de 45% au financement des
transports publics et cela s'ajoutent à
l'obligation qui s'impose aux employeurs
de financer 50% des abonnements de
transport en commun alors salarié moi je
veux insister sur un premier point c'est
que le versement mobilité en 2022
augmente de 7% par rapport à 2021 ça
représente déjà 200 millions d'euros de
fiscalité supplémentaires et je parle
ici pour la seule
IDFM Île-de-France mobilité 200 millions
d'euros de versements mobilité en plus
déjà cette cette année
je pense qu'il y a des questions à se
poser sur le modèle le versement
mobilité représente déjà 40% des
ressources d'idfm n'est pas tenable je
le dis de notre point de vue d'augmenter
sans cesse les impôts de production et
aboutirent un modèle uniquement financé
par les prélèvements obligatoires
on souhaite encore une fois non pas
augmenter les impôts qui pèsent sur le
travail et la production mais on cherche
à continuer à les baisser donc on ne
peut pas être favorable avec cette ligne
ça ne serait pas tenable à notre sens
pour nos entreprises ce ne serait pas
tenable pour notre économie encore une
fois il y a un travail qui est mené
activement avec la première ministre
avec Christophe Béchu pour trouver non
mais j'ai dit que je ne faisais pas
d'intervention avant la discussion des
amendements comme le rapporteur général
mais que je m'exprimerai en réponse aux
premiers amendements sur l'ensemble des
amendements je me suis exprimé sur les
amendements qui viennent d'être
présentés en disant pourquoi je ne suis
pas pour augmenter le versement mobilité
d'une manière générale je m'exprime
ensuite comme l'a fait le rapporteur
général sur l'ensemble des amendements
qui viennent en discussion ce qui nous
permettra de gagner du temps sur la
suite je crois que c'était souhaité par
le président rénal et par un certain
nombre de groupes donc évidemment il y a
un travail qui se poursuit sur puisque
c'est quand même le cas le plus on va
dire
urgence signaler sur la situation
financière d'Île-de-France mobilité
il y a encore une fois un certain nombre
d'outils qui existent aujourd'hui pour
Île-de-France mobilité il y a la
question des dessertes il y a la
question de la productivité et la
question de la masse salariale et de
l'absentéisme il y a la question de la
tarification il y a la question des
économies qui peuvent être faites 1%
d'économies sur le fonctionnement c'est
100 millions d'euros 1% d'économies sur
le fonctionnement c'est 100 millions
d'euros moi je redis la disponibilité du
gouvernement dans son ensemble et plus
particulièrement de la première ministre
de mon collègue Christophe Béchu
évidemment mon collègue Clément Boon
pour continuer à travailler avec les
élus de la région Île-de-France sur ce
sujet là et pour les autres amendements
vous aurez compris pourquoi nous sommes
défavorables à une augmentation du
versement mobilité avis défavorable
alors nous avons donc pour l'instant là
nous prononcer sur les amendements 335
336 et 1400 donc sur ces amendements là
j'ai des interventions de Monsieur
docius d'abord ensuite de Monsieur
Savoldelli et enfin de Monsieur ben
Laroche et de Monsieur Dominati oui moi
je suis pas très satisfait de la réponse
du ministre qui mélange 1 un peu tout le
c'est pas un impôts qui est basé sur la
masse salariale déjà ensuite au moment
de faire des économies sur le
fonctionnement alors qu'on sait que les
différentes Awans ont du mal à recruter
actuellement des chauffeurs et donc je
ne vois pas bien où on peut faire des de
l'économie et puis en fait c'est une
mesure d'égalité en demande à ce que les
AOM or Île-de-France puissent exercer
les mêmes taux quand il de France après
ces mesures aussi d'autonomie des
collectivités on parle de temps on parle
pas d'augmentation automatique au taquet
des taux fixés et puis on est quand même
dans une période assez particulière on a
aidé énormément au carburant donc au
déplacement dans les voitures
individuelles puisqu'il y a des endroits
où on ne peut pas faire autrement mais
on peut pas se contenter de ce constat
là si on ne peut pas faire comment c'est
parce qu'on a besoin d'investissement
aussi dans les transports en commun et
dans et dans les transports collectifs
on est en train de d'imposer des zones à
faible émission dans les grandes
agglomérations on a besoin donc de
développer des alternatives à aux
véhicules individuels thermiques et donc
il y a un moment il va falloir investir
et là actuellement les collectivités
sont dans un moment très compliqué pour
investir et donc c'est le moment de
faire participer la richesse nationale à
au déplacement au transport en commun et
quand j'entends que ça peut être un
facteur de frein à l'attractivité moi je
pense le contraire je pense que une
agglomération Kia un certain nombre de
d'équipements de transport collectifs
efficace sont des agglomérations qui
sont attractives aussi pour le tissu
économique voilà ensuite donc monsieur
ça vole des lits
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues moi
aussi je voudrais réagir à vos propos
monsieur le ministre vous parlez des 500
millions c'est votre estimation de la
contribution des entreprises
au versement transport si on augmente le
taux c'est pas ça c'est ça ok donc mais
les entreprises
faut les défendre y compris je trouve
que ces amendements défendent les
entreprises parce que si on laisse ce
continuer la dégradation et les
lamoinement des salariés du point de vue
des transports en commun je vais vous
dire que ça va coûter une blinde aux
entreprises
parce qu'il garde l'absentéisme parce
qu'il y avait des taux de productivité
qui vont baisser etc et il va y avoir
une défiance des salariés vis-à-vis de
l'entreprise ça va coûter combien ça à
nos entreprises donc ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose enfin
moi je voudrais que vous nous expliquer
quel est votre diagnostic réel de l'état
de la situation de la RATP la SNCF
excusez moi mais mes chers collègues ils
sont qui sont pas de la région
parisienne vraiment il y a aucune mais
pour ceux qui sont on est unanime ici je
pense avoir une situation dégradation
jamais connue de la RATP la SNCF
pourquoi vous en parlez pas de ça
troisième élément monsieur le ministre
vous le savez très bien qu'il y a c'est
plus qu'une menace
m'éclate présidente de la ville de
France mobilité madame Pécresse à la
région va augmenter le Pass Navigo mais
en augmentant le passe Navigo monsieur
le ministre les 50% de versent les
entreprises elles vont aussi être
contributives donc il va bien y avoir un
effort des entreprises donc on mérite
vraiment c'est un sujet qui mérite une
autre argumentation vraiment sérieuse
rigoureuse argumentée
une partie de ce que je voulais
également dire à monsieur le ministre
c'est le ministre en fait je vous sors
mal à l'aise je sens mal à l'aise avec
ce versement de mobilité vous nous
reparlez de la CVAE le Sénat a pris une
décision là-dessus quasiment unanime
vous la remettez encore d'accord mais en
tout cas c'est notre décision nous
pensons nous qu'il faut aller dans ce
sens et justement c'est parce que nous
avons pris cette décision que nous
pensons également que l'augmentation des
taux a possible dans le respect de
l'autonomie de chacune des collectivités
de les fixer nous n'apposant rien
monsieur le ministre nous laissons la
possibilité nous faisons confiance aux
gens qui sont dans les exécutifs des
collectivités pour savoir à quel point
dans la discussion avec les employeurs
elles peuvent augmenter ses taux et à
quel point elles en ont besoin pour
développer les services de transport en
commun parce que leur territoire en ont
besoin parce que l'État n'a passé assez
parce que face au défi climatique parce
que face à tous les toutes les charges
supplémentaires que subissent les les
collectivités aujourd'hui il faut bien
trouver des moyens qui sont des moyens
qui ne pèsent pas beaucoup à personne
qui seront discutés monsieur le ministre
entre les collectivités et les
entreprises pourquoi ne pas offrir cette
possibilité parce que vous êtes bloqué
sur la décision que le Sénat a pris sur
le CVAE ecoutez on a pris une décision
toute connaissance de cause et en
fonction de ce que nous pensions être
utile pour notre pays et de la même
façon monsieur le ministre accepter que
les collectivités puissent augmenter là
où il existe les déversements mobilité
puisse augmenter les taux en discussion
en fonction de leur contexte en fonction
de leurs besoins et en fonction des
discussions qu'elles ont avec les
entreprises qui existent dans leur
territoire Dieu nominatif
merci monsieur le Président moi aussi
monsieur le rapporteur je voulais réagir
un peu
aux propos que vous avez souligné parce
qu'en réalité on a oublié deux facteurs
dans ce débat le premier c'est la
particularité de l'implication des
entreprises dans les transports publics
nous sommes l'un des seuls pays où les
entreprises sont directement associées
au financement des transports publics
que ce soit en Allemagne en Espagne en
Italie aux États-Unis au Canada c'est à
chaque fois un dialogue avec deux
acteurs l'argent l'acteur public soit
l'état soit les collectivités
territoriales et l'usager il n'y a que
dans le système d'Île-de-France au
départ dans le financement de
l'Île-de-France qu'on a impliqué les
entreprises
et c'est un système pratique depuis des
décennies on implique le financement par
les entreprises de France à notre
système de transport deuxième
particularité l'Île-de-France a un
statut particulier comme vous l'avez
sousigné et depuis des décennies puisque
c'est la région capitale nous n'avons
pas la liberté les collectivités
territoriales et le conseil régional n'a
pas la vraie liberté pour la gestion des
transports et il y a une implication de
l'État l'État se repose je dirais sur le
STIF soi-disant l'autorité organisatrice
doit faire les choses et en réalité au
nom de la paix social la gauche depuis
des années souligne effectivement à
chaque fois qu'il y a un problème
financier la nécessité d'augmenter le
versement mobilité
c'est subtil parce que en plus les
entreprises payent deux fois une fois
par le versement mobilité et une fois
pour l'augmentation du Pass Navigo comme
l'a dit mon collègue
ça veut dire effectivement puisque il y
aura
théoriquement cette augmentation de
cette taxe pour empêcher une
augmentation du poste Navigo mais en
réalité il y aura les deux choses pour
l'Île-de-France l'augmentation du Pass
Navigo pour les usagers ou les
entreprises vont payer 50%. et
l'augmentation du versement mobilité ou
les entreprises contribuent à plus de
50% de la totalité
l'État ne prend pas ses responsabilités
les collectivités toriales non plus et
l'usager paye à peu près la même chose
que dans les autres pays
m'exprimerai sur les autres amendements
après nous avons donc à nous prononcer
sur les trois amendements qui ont fait
l'objet d'un double avis défavorable le
335 de Monsieur benaroche monsieur
bruyet
je veux juste dire pour nos collègues
qui ne sont pas d'Île-de-France que ces
amendements de concernent pas
l'Île-de-France et que nous allons avoir
le débat sur l'Île-de-France en Suisse
elles ont de plus pour que nous
tranchions tout de suite donc je mets
aux voix l'amendement 335 de Monsieur
benaroche avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
qui est contre
l'ascension et pas adopté
sur l'amendement 336 même vote
sur l'amendement 1400 même vote
nous poursuivons avec l'amendement 403
de Monsieur le rugulier qu'il présente
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais faire un focus sur la situation
de la métropole Aix-Marseille
vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas sans le
savoir Monsieur le Ministre que le
Président de la République a annoncé un
plan Marseille en grand il y a de cela
un an et demi
un milliard sur la table 250 millions
d'euros de subvention 750 millions
d'avance remboursables et derrière ça un
plan mobilité de plus de 3,5 milliards
d'euros
et il est clair que pour financer ce
plan mobilité il faut trouver d'autres
ressources d'autres levier fiscaux que
la taxe foncière bâtie ou non bâtie donc
les contribuables c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous propose ce
déplafonnement sachant que le budget
annexe des transports est déjà en
déficit structurel déjà déséquilibre
structurel comblé par le budget général
de plus de 120 millions d'euros par an
que l'ambition sur Marseille en grand
c'est 700 millions d'euros 400 millions
sur le budget général 300 millions sur
budget transport pour 2023 2030 et je
vous le dis clairement sans se
déblafonnement qui pourra être et c'est
tout l'objet de l'amendement
synonyme de justice fiscale également
puisqu'on propose un amendement de
réguler
ce taux de VM en fonction des bassins de
mobilité donc il y aura une baisse sur
des secteurs où l'offre de transport et
la plus faible et une augmentation sur
les secteurs ou l'offre de transport est
satisfaisante ou sur des secteurs qui
nécessitent un investissement conséquent
le ministre sans la validation de cet
amendement c'est la santé financière de
la métropole qui auront mis en question
et on ouvre une crise institutionnelle
majeure au niveau de cette métropole qui
représente je vous le rappelle quatre
fois le Grand Paris et 6 fois le Grand
Lyon merci monsieur le rapporteur sur
l'amendement
monsieur le ministre
donc
défavorable à partager donc je me vois
là maintenant qu'elles sont trois avec
deux amis défavorables qui est pour
monsieur benaroche chers
nous avons je crois tous la volonté tout
de même de ne pas trop allonger les
débats donc si on n'avait pas 3 ou 4
interventions par amendement ce serait
mieux monsieur ben Laroche je comprends
bien monsieur le Président c'est la
étant dit Stéphane Le ruguellier l'a dit
c'est amendement et le versement
mobilité peut mettre plus ou moins en
péril en fait les finances de la
métropole expertise province alors j'ai
défendu un amendement qui était un
amendement général qui concernait le
National et qui concernait en fait à
remettre un équilibre au niveau national
entre les différents taux des versements
mobilité
vous ne l'avez pas accepté aujourd'hui
on a l'exception de Paris dont on va
rediscuter qu'on va peut-être augmenter
ce qui fera encore une différence plus
grande avec le reste du pays et
maintenant quelque part on crée une
deuxième exception qui est celle de
Marseille elle est justifiée cette
exception donc c'est une exception pour
laquelle c'est un amendement pour lequel
je voterai bien entendu mais avouer
chers amis que ne pas permettre aux
collectivités dans leur ensemble en
France de profiter du versement mobilité
comme elle l'entende là où c'est
possible pour permettre
d'améliorer les réseaux de transport en
commun c'est quand même un peu
incohérent avec le reste des décisions
que nous avons prises nous continuons à
prendre donc je vais vous montrer cette
abonnement puisqu'il permettra aussi du
coup à la métropole d'expertise Provence
d'avoir un certain nombre de revenus
nécessaires
rue du lieu oui merci quelques minutes
quand même encore sur Marseille sans le
vote de cet amendement c'est le plan
grand Marseille qui échoue
lamentablement il faut le savoir
Monsieur ministre vous avez une
responsabilité vous mettez avis
défavorable sans sans explication je ne
comprends pas je vous rappelle
simplement que le fait de déplafonner le
VM à 2,95 en termes de recettes
maximales c'est 160 millions d'euros par
an fléchés sur le budget transport de la
métropole on vous propose un
déplafonnement progressif réguler et il
y a des simulations qui ont été faites
pour lever uniquement 80 millions
d'euros ce qui nous suffirait pour
remplir nos obligations si je veux dire
en termes de collectivité par rapport à
ce plan Marseillan grand rappelons que
les transports c'est le sang qui irrigue
les organes vitaux donc sans cette
amendement malheureusement c'est
l'ensemble des plans qui échouent merci
nous nous prononçons qui est pour cet
amendement
qui est contre
mais pas adopté
maintenant 840 et à 4 amendements
identiques discussion comme une pardon
le premier c'est 840 monsieur Bocquet
monsieur Savoldelli monsieur président
Laurent
merci monsieur le Président donc sur
cette question de l'augmentation du
versement transport mobilité en
Île-de-France d'abord je pense qu'il
faut bien comprendre de quoi on parle
stop la galère c'est le cri d'alarme
qu'on lance les élus communistes de la
région Île-de-France il y a maintenant
plus d'un mois depuis ce jour il y a des
milliers de gens qui signent des
pétitions tous les jours sous ce mot
d'ordre parce que la situation est
intenable parce que le nombre de gens
qui sont actuellement dans les
transports il est le même qu'avant la
pandémie mais on a retrouvé nulle part
le niveau de trafic suffisant il manque
des rames il manque des métros il manque
des RER et donc la situation elle est
insupportable c'est des gens qui
n'arrivent pas au boulot à l'heure qui
ne peuvent pas récupérer leurs enfants
alors le soir etc c'est une situation
invivable qui ne pourra pas durer c'est
pas seulement la question que les
comptes financiers sont dans le rouge ce
qui est vrai aussi
ça c'est la première chose que je veux
dire la deuxième chose c'est que les
causes elles sont connues il y a pas
assez d'argent pour investir dans les
rames il y a pas assez d'argent pour
investir dans la maintenance du matériel
il y a pas assez d'argent pour embaucher
parce qu'on manque de chauffeur on
manque de conducteur il y a pas assez
d'argent pour investir dans la formation
donc il faut trouver des recettes
supplémentaires on peut tourner autour
du pot c'est absolument indispensable
nous nous proposons l'augmentation du
versement transforme mobilité des
entreprises avec les chiffres qui a
donné monsieur le ministre tout à
l'heure
je veux redire à presque a dit Pascal ça
vole Delhi que c'est ça déjà été prouvé
parce qu'on a déjà utilisé cette recette
c'est la recette la plus efficace pour
résoudre les problèmes en Île-de-France
nous nous proposons de la cibler sur les
entreprises qui sont les plus les mieux
dotés et qui bénéficient le plus du
transport donc les arrondissements du
centre de Paris les arrondissements qui
vont le long en gros des Champs-Élysées
jusqu'au quartier d'affaires de La
Défense et quelques autres dans les
Hauts-de-Seine et à Paris donc c'est une
augmentation en plus ciblée que nous
proposons efficace et si nous ne faisons
pas cette augmentation et bien nous
aurons l'augmentation du passen Navigo
parce que monsieur le ministre vous n'en
avez pas parlé de ça mais le 7 décembre
c'est le 7 décembre que Valérie Pécresse
à propose d'augmenter le versement
transport à plus de 90 euros donc c'est
là où l'autre
vous proposons une recette juste
monsieur
l'intégralité de l'augmentation
que leur situation de transport des
aujourd'hui totalement
monsieur Breuillet pour l'amendement
de la vie quotidienne de millions de
personnes qui vivent une situation
extrêmement gradée dégradée tous les
jours il y a des missions annulées des
bus des métros des RER et des millions
de personnes se pressent parfois sur les
quais au risque d'accident et même je
vous le dis de Jacquie je suis usagé de
ces transports en commun j'ai vu des
situations de tension énorme dans le RER
j'ai répondu à l'invitation de la
président de la Région
Île-de-France qui n'est pas exactement
une amie politique parce qu'elle a
attiré l'attention sur le graphe danger
pour Île-de-France mobilité d'une
impasse financière de 950 millions et je
le dis sur tous les rangs il y a une
urgence de répondre à cette situation
qui concerne les salariés qui concernent
aussi chers collègues les entreprises
parce que quand il y a des retards d'une
heure pour rejoindre le boulot ça n'est
pas non plus bon pour les entreprises
le transport le versement mobilité vous
ne voulez pas l'augmenter si on
l'augmente pas nous allons augmenter le
Pass Navigo qui est actuellement à 75
euros à 100 euros les entreprises en
paieront quand même 50 %. donc elle
prendront de toute façon l'augmentation
mais nous allons dire à des usagers qui
sont malmenés dans les transports au
lieu de payer 75 euros vous allez en
payer 100 et en plus vous êtes
transfoque transporté comme des bestiaux
parce que c'est ça qu'il s'agit
aujourd'hui alors nous avons voté chers
collègues merci nous avons voté chers
collègues la baisse de la TVA à 5,5
c'est une très bonne nouvelle j'espère
qu'elle restera monsieur le ministre
dans le 49-3 j'attends votre réponse
moi je soutiens la proposition qu'a fait
madame Pécresse d'une hausse du
versement transport moduler selon la
richesse quand on paye son siège social
ou son siège d'entreprise à la défense
ou dans le cœur de Paris excusez-moi
c'est pas le montant du versement
mobilité qui va nuire à l'équilibre
budgétaire de l'entreprise donc nous
avons une nécessité ardente de répondre
aux besoins des
usagers et je serai étonné que vous ne
soyez pas solidaire avec votre
présidente de région
amendements c'est son 15
qui défend pardon qui défend
l'amendement 715
président karucci le 715
je vous propose une hausse du versement
mobilité en Île-de-France pour éviter la
baisse de l'offre en transport en commun
comme ça a été dit ou bien une
augmentation exorbitante du Pass Navigo
pour les usagers la hausse qui est
demandedée et inférieure à celle de
l'inflation
et enfin Monsieur capo canelas que la
parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je crois que nous sommes
depuis quelques minutes sur un débat qui
concerne des millions d'usagers des
transports et ça vient d'être dit par
notre Breuillet en Île-de-France
malheureusement compte tenu de la
caractéristique il avait testé du réseau
compte tenu du besoin d'investissement
contenu des effets de la crise du covid
du manque de conducteur de chauffeur
actuellement c'était déjà une galère et
ça devient de plus en plus difficile
qu'il nous dit pas que il attend les bus
une demi-heure qui ne nous dit pas que
la ligne 13 ou la ligne B ou les autres
lignes sont saturées et donc on est face
à cette grande difficulté s'ajoute le
constat que l'année prochaine il y a
potentiellement 900 millions d'euros qui
vont manquer avec de France mobilité et
Monsieur ministre évidemment personne
n'a envie d'augmenter les impôts mais
personne n'a envie non plus d'augmenter
le Pass Navigo parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre solution et vous nous dites que
vous souhaitez pas augmenter le passé
le versement mobilité mais dans ce cas
est-ce que l'État va changer les avances
les modifier faire une dotation faire
une subvention et de France mobilité il
faut une conférence leur apporteur la
proposer c'est une bonne chose mais nous
n'arriverons à résoudre ce problème que
par un panier de recettes Gilles Carrez
a proposé il y a quelques temps de ça
dans un rapport de la Fondation montagne
d'augmenter un certain nombre de
recettes de poches ça fait partie des
choses vous avez monsieur le ministre
indiqué qui avait des efforts à faire
les transporteurs qui sont engagés les
collectivités apportent 200 millions
aussi mais simplement ce que nous disons
c'est qu'il faudra bien trouver une
solution qui passe c'est vrai et
malheureusement par une augmentation du
Pass Navigo mais aussi par un effort sur
le versement mobilité on peut critiquer
le versement mobilité mais il existe et
je crois qu'on ne peut pas manquer
malheureusement de l'utiliser donc nous
proposons Philippe Tabor et moi
d'augmenter le plafond de 5%, ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il faudra aller forcément à
ce niveau là ça veut dire qu'on se donne
cette possibilité là de
que la première option nous avait
envisagé nous avons fait un geste pour
entendre le besoin de ne pas trop
augmenter ce versement mobilité mais il
faut le faire quand même j'ai déjà trois
autres amandes de trois autres orateurs
inscrits avant que nous votions sur ces
premiers amendements donc monsieur
Ouzoulias si chacun peut faire un effort
de brièveté
bien sûr merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mais mes chers
collègues je voudrais apporter trois
points au débat le premier point la
dette aujourd'hui d'IDF mobilisée c'est
7 milliards 7 milliards de déficit le
deuxième point c'est que Monsieur
Édouard Philippe en janvier 2020 avait
donné la garantie du gouvernement
d'assurer le financement pérenne des
coûts de fonctionnement du Grand Paris
Express l'engagement n'a pas été tenu
monsieur le ministre l'engagement n'a
pas été tenu troisième point vous savez
très bien que pour les Jeux Olympiques
les promesses de la France en matière de
transport urbain ne sont pas tenus une
nouvelle fois et il y a eu un transfert
de charges de l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques vers
IDF mobilité c'est-à-dire que IDF
mobilité va financer sur ses propres
deniers l'installation de ligne de bus
de ligne de bus électrique monsieur le
ministre de ligne de bus en site propre
pour permettre pour permettre le
voiturage des athlètes et des
journalistes ça c'est un surcoût énorme
qui est pris à la charge de de
IDF mobilité et qui n'est pas financé
par l'État voilà donc là il y a une
somme de mesure qui pèse de façon
structurelle sur l'organisme des des
transports en Île-de-France et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une charge qui est
complètement insupportable il s'agit pas
d'absentéisme ce ministre il s'agit d'un
déficit structurel qui dure depuis 20
ans et pour les collègues qui qui aura
encore des doutes je vous propose demain
matin de vous retrouver à la gare de
Bourg-la-Reine mais à 7h30 parce qu'à 8h
c'est fini il y a plus de place merci
monsieur le Président ensuite donc
Madame bouran
oui merci monsieur le Président
voilà moi j'interviens à la fois en élu
francilienne et élu de grande couronnes
en grande couronne on sait pas faire on
ne sait pas payer un pass Navigo à 100
euros c'est pas possible c'est juste pas
possible tous les efforts qui ont été
concédés par la région par les
différentes collectivités conseils
généraux et régions ont fait en sorte de
désenclaver nos territoires et des
enclavés c'est quoi c'est permettre aux
Franciliens de circuler avec un coût qui
est supportable si on ne modifie rien
aujourd'hui j'entends par là bien
entendu l'aide de l'État vous nous dites
monsieur le ministre augmenter faire 1%
des économies sur notre budget est-ce
que vous savez quoi vous parlez vous
membres du gouvernement alors que nous
appelons de nos vœux en permanence des
économies du budget sur l'état
à la région Île-de-France nous avons
fait ces économies en un seul mandat de
milliards d'économies aujourd'hui nous
en sommes à 5 milliards et nous avons
réinvesti et c'est ce dont nous avons
besoin donc réinvestis aussi ce qui a
profité à Île-de-France mobilité donc
vous l'avez compris ni lulude grande
couronne mais aussi une élue
francilienne alors que se passe-t-il
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un départ
dans une région qui compte 12 millions
d'habitants chaque jour il y a 9
millions 300 000 déplacements dans notre
région c'est la région dans laquelle il
y a le plus de déplacements et
aujourd'hui on voudrait nous empêcher de
le faire d'autre part les franciliens et
notamment les les habitants de grande
couronne participent à l'effort pour les
Jeux Olympiques participe à l'effort
pour la création du Grand Paris Express
il n'enveront si si ça se trouve
absolument pas la couleur donc il faut
absolument mettre tout le monde autour
d'une table aidé et faire en sorte de
trouver les financements et aujourd'hui
nous n'avons d'autres moyens que donne
d'augmenter effectivement cette
contribution mobilité merci
monsieur le rapportait vous avez bien
donné favorable sur les trois
amendements
ce que oui pardon puisque j'avais dit à
vie du gouvernement c'est effectivement
avis des favorable c'est bien la vie du
gouvernement les favorable
donc nous avons encore monsieur Ferro
inscrit sur ces trois amendements
voilà
merci monsieur le Président la situation
elle est très grave celle des transports
en Île-de-France et par ailleurs les
transports en Île-de-France sont devant
un mur financier pour les mois qui
viennent moi je vais faire de la
politique politiqueienne et vous parler
de la gestion de Madame Pécresse c'est
pas le lieu ici on est là pour chercher
des solutions mais chers philippe
Dominati c'est pas la gauche qui demande
l'augmentation du versement mobilité
c'est Valérie Pécresse la présidente de
région et d'Île-de-France mobilité qui
nous a demandé d'engage de nous engager
dans cette voie pourquoi n'a-t-elle fait
parce que les économies de
fonctionnement on peut sûrement acheter
trois trombones de moins mais économies
de fonctionnement monsieur le ministre
ça s'arrête tout quand il n'y aura plus
un seul conducteur de bus volontaire on
en aura fait beaucoup des économies de
fonctionnement on n'aura pas résolu les
problèmes des transports publics la
réalité c'est que les transports publics
en Île-de-France sont aussi un des
éléments d'attractivité essentielles de
la vie économique de l'Île-de-France et
donc du pays et les entreprises en
bénéficient également alors les
transports en commun ils ont fait partie
des demi oubliés du quoi qu'il en coûte
nous nous avions dénoncé les avances
remboursables plutôt qu'une prise en
charge globale aujourd'hui il y a les
collectivités qui vont mettre la main à
la poche c'est déjà prévu en particulier
la région la ville de Paris et le
département des Hauts-de-Seine il y a la
TVA 5 5% que nous avons voté ici si elle
est maintenue l'étape participera ainsi
au financement alors est-ce que les
entreprises pourraient aussi participer
à cette tour de table financier pour
passer ce mur financier je pense que ce
serait logique que ce serait équitable
que ce serait juste et donc nous
voterons ces amendements qui proposent
d'augmenter le versement mobilité madame
Lavarde
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
j'ai entendu que certains étaient
favorables à une taxation premium je
voudrais juste rappeler que les
entreprises de cette zone premium c'est
déjà celle sur lesquelles il y a
quelques années on a fait porter une
surtaxe sur les bureaux de 40%. ces
entreprises vous êtes bien content de
les trouver quand vous habitez un tout
petit peu au-delà dans la grande
couronne mais que vous avez un RER qui
vous y amène directement quand demain
elles iront se localiser dans les hauts
de France en Normandie parce que
maintenant à l'heure du télétravail
c'est assez facile d'avoir ces salariés
plus loin que son lieu d'habitation on
sera tous contents et je voudrais juste
te dire que aujourd'hui les entreprises
elles participent en Île-de-France à
plus de 50% du financement des
transports que un rapport du Sénat
transpartisan cosigné par des membres de
chacun des groupes politiques a quand
même écrit taxé toujours davantage les
entreprises franciliennes
a fortiori ne constitue donc pas une
solution acceptable et dans le rapport
annuel de la Cour des comptes alors
certains décrit la Cour des comptes mais
au moins c'est une analyse qui a été
faite de manière posée rapport annuel de
février 2022
on parle de piste d'évolution justement
sur IDFM et dans ces pistes prioritaires
aucune ne parle du de l'augmentation du
versement mobilité et il y a notamment
une des propositions qui rejoint une des
propositions qui avait été faire par le
groupe de travail donc il me semble
vraiment intéressant de prendre cette
conférence de financement qui est
proposée par le rapporteur général une
conférence de financement qui tiendra
très rapidement mais pour qu'on discute
de l'ensemble des hypothèses plutôt que
de décider là rapidement de mettre une
nouvelle taxe qui ne résoudra que
partiellement le problème parce que
comme le disait aussi ce rapport le
financement du Grand Paris Express n'est
absolument pas assuré aujourd'hui on a
trouvé les ressources pour financer la
construction mais demain comment
fera-t-on pour financer la circulation
des trains
monsieur Dominati
[Applaudissements]
et vous êtes encore 5 ensuite
oui ce qui a changé monsieur le
Président dans ce débat par rapport aux
autres années sur cette discussion
budgétaire c'est qu'effectivement il y a
urgence pour l'usager et presque tous
les groupes politiques ont dit par
contre la Convention nationale que
propose le rapporteur ou un certain
nombre d'élus ça n'a pas de sens ce qui
compte c'est de changer le statut faire
en sorte que l'Île-de-France et les
mêmes pouvoirs que les autres régions de
France c'est en cela qu'il faudrait une
véritable réforme mais on n'a pas le
temps de le faire d'ici les Jeux
Olympiques et par contre on ne doit pas
se mettre d'accord sur le dos des
entreprises qui financent comme l'a dit
Madame Navarre à 50% le mobilité
transport parce que personne ne veut
entamer le dialogue parce que le conflit
entre la région l'État les départements
c'est trop simple d'essayer de faire
perdurer un système qui ne fonctionne
pas depuis 30 ans sous prétexte de ne
pas vouloir rompre la paix sociale en
réalité c'est la région capitale il est
temps de mettre les choses sur la table
effectivement
un problème de qualité a lieu dans nos
services publics mais on n'ose pas
aborder le problème donc c'est pour cela
qu'effectivement pour ma part je ne
m'associerai pas à vous fait de voter le
une augmentation du versement transport
une thèse que la gauche défend depuis
des années c'est normal elle est dans sa
logique maintenant chacun prendra la
route qu'il voudra prendre
monsieur le président caoutchi
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
ce que je regrette dans tout ça c'est
qu'on a l'impression que l'État est
ailleurs
moi j'ai des souvenirs et certains s'en
souviennent peut-être en 2014 lorsque le
président Huchon a voulu mettre en place
le Pass Navigo j'étais alors président
de la commission des finances de la
région je m'y étais opposé en disant que
nous n'avions pas les moyens et le
président le choix avait fait venir
Manuel Valls alors Premier ministre qui
avait pris un certain nombre
d'engagement sur le financement par
l'état des transports publics en
Île-de-France ces engagements n'ont pas
été respectés de la même manière en 2020
Édouard Philippe 1er ministre a écrit
des choses tristes simples très claires
sur l'engagement financier de l'État sur
les transports publics en Île-de-France
ces engagements n'ont pas été tenus
alors aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec
pardon monsieur le ministre c'est pas
vous perso mais on se retrouve avec un
gouvernement qui dit trouver une
solution qui reste en de mais qui est en
réalité n'a pas assumé et vous n'avez
notamment pas assumé monsieur le
ministre et je m'étais opposé je m'en
souviens encore en commission mix
paritaire faire en sorte que face au
covid ce soit essentiellement des
avances remboursables et pas des
dotations parce qu'évidemment c'est le
gouvernement qui avait imposé un certain
nombre de règles de mesure de rigueur
sur le covid mais après il dit bah non
on vous avance mais il faudra rembourser
pardon de vous dire ce qui simplifierait
les choses mais je sais bien que vous
n'avez pas la marge de manœuvre c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous puissiez dire que
une partie des avances remboursables se
transforment en dotation parce qu'en
vrai il faudrait que l'État quand même
qui est intervenu massivement sur
l'essence sur les sur un certain nombre
d'éléments privés ce disent que les
transports publics notamment en
Île-de-France où il y a six à 7 millions
d'usagers tous les jours dans les
transports publics reprenez la
responsabilité incertaine de choses vous
ne pouvez pas que garder la
responsabilité de nommer le PDG de la
RATP de nommé le PDG de la SNCF mais en
parallèle de ne pas financer
madame Darko
merci monsieur le Président beaucoup de
choses ont été dites mais pour aller
dans le sens de mon collègue Roger
caoutchi un nouvel exemple aussi la SNCF
a notamment dans en Essonne supprimer
l'ensemble des guichets d'informations
voyageurs c'est la région Île-de-France
qui a été obligée de doter la plupart
des gares de ces guichets parce qu'on
sait très bien que certains n'ont pas
les moyens ou ne savent pas forcément
juste fonctionner de manière automatique
pour reprendre aussi certains collègues
moi aussi je me suis bien sur poser des
questions j'en ai parlé avec Christine
depuis plusieurs jours
taxer à nouveau les entreprises alors
qu'ils sont aux abois bien évidemment
c'est compliqué simplement on défend
aujourd'hui plutôt les TPE PME parce que
si en effet le Pass Navigo passe à 90 ou
100 euros ce sont tous les toutes les
tous les salariés enfin tous les
entreprises de moins de 11 salariés qui
enfin de manière rétroactive seront
obligés de payer plus les 50% de
réduction à chacun de leurs salariés
donc on est plutôt à vouloir défendre
ces petites entreprises désolé pour les
grosses on leur demande encore un effort
mais en effet comme l'a dit un de mes
collègues d'avoir des gens qui arrivent
à leur dans les entreprises font
fonctionner les entreprises donc voilà
bien évidemment je soutiendrai c'est de
ces deux amendements et je soutiens la
présidente de la région qui essaie de
faire beaucoup d'efforts pour
restructurer l'ensemble des réseaux
féérés
bien que provincial et on me l'a assez
reproché
si j'ai porté cette amendement c'est que
le combat d'idfm pour éviter de baisser
drastiquement son offre de transport en
commun me semble juste tout d'abord nous
ne pouvons imputer ses besoins de
financement urgent une mauvaise gestion
bien au contraire et ça a été rappelé
sans recherche d'économie c'est bien
plus que
750 millions qu'il faudrait trouver
deuxièmement parce qu'idefm est la plus
importante autorité organisatrice de
France avec la prise en charge en
moyenne de près de 10 millions de
voyageurs par jour troisièmement parce
que les projets d'extension et de
modernisation et ça a été dit du réseau
arrive 2023 l'après exploitation du
Grand Paris Express 2020
Orly le RER jusqu'à Nanterre et sans
financement cela a été également rappelé
pourtant promis par le célèbre ancien
Premier ministre Edouard Philippe
parce que l'effort et la quatrième
raison c'est parce que l'effort qui est
demandé est collectif on demande un
effort à l'état et ça a été très bien
dit par Roger caroutchi on demande un
effort aux collectivités et Valérie
Pécresse montre l'exemple on demande un
effort aux usagers et on demande un
effort enfin aux entreprises et à 4
c'est tout ça mais la charge sera
beaucoup moins lourde à porter que à un
seul enfin pour les entreprises et leur
la très justement dit également une
augmentation modérée du vm sera moins
lourde à porter notamment pour les plus
petites entreprises qu'une augmentation
de 25 euros du Pass Navigo alors certes
votre idée chers Jean-François Husson de
conférence me paraît particulièrement
intéressantes mais désolé par rapport à
l'urgence de la situation c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vais maintenir
mon amendement avec toute la conviction
qui existe
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues moi
j'ai le sentiment notre groupe que le
groupe communiste pense que l'État est
en train de fuir ses responsabilités sur
le sujet
et moi je le dis clairement depuis le
début par les silences ou par les
argumentations
semble avoir des ambitions électoristes
sur la région mais ça n'intéresse pas
les usagers des transports et ça n'a
rien à voir avec les transports publics
parce que quand même ils doivent
mobilité monsieur le ministre est en
quasi faillite
capacité de désendettement monsieur le
ministre
14,57 années vous avez comme moi une
commune en France une commune quant à la
12 ans d'endettement elle est saisie par
la CRC ou la Cour des comptes pour avoir
une trajectoire de redressement donc on
a une situation de terrible de crise
vous avez l'agence maudite à dégrader la
notation d'Île-de-France mobilité
et c'est en-têtement pour être dans la
clarté va encore plus s'alourdir si
Madame Pécresse décide de privatiser les
bus de RATP ça sera un endettement
encore qui va être rajouté d'une somme
de 4,9 milliards d'impôts donc voilà
c'est pas possible
et c'est pourquoi je vous le dis avec
solidité il y a une urgence on peut pas
nous dire
navette et on peut pas attendre en
Île-de-France mais aussi sur d'autres
territoires un nouveau PLF je sais pas
du numéro combien on est dans une
situation d'urgente c'est pourquoi
devant cette urgence et bien nous
mettrons scrutin public l'amendement que
nous avons déposé merci
madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président très
rapidement je voudrais vous dire qu'en
tant que président de la commission des
affaires économiques je ne suis pas très
joyeuse de demander aux entreprises une
fiscalité supplémentaire mais Monsieur
le Ministre ce n'est pas cette assemblée
qui demande une fiscalité supplémentaire
c'est vous c'est vous car vous êtes
sourd à la situation d'urgence qui a été
décrite par l'ensemble des groupes et
l'ensemble des sénateurs sur les
différents groupes je dis pas l'ensemble
pardon monsieur
c'est vous qui êtes sourd faisons une
suspension de séance Monsieur le
Ministre donnez-nous une solution pour
Île-de-France mobilité et immédiatement
nous retirons notre amendement de
fiscalité supplémentaire alors cet
amendement de fiscalité supplémentaire
si il est amené à voter moi je ne suis
pas content parce que je ne veux pas
augmenter la fiscalité des entreprises
mais c'est un manque d'appel pour dans
la navette que vous preniez vos
responsabilités et que vous trouviez une
situation une réponse aux situations que
vous vous avez provoqué vous même les
Jeux Olympiques la demande de transport
vous l'avez vous l'avez provoqué
vous-même monsieur le malmise ah je suis
contente que vous réagissiez au moins il
y a quelques propos qui vous font réagir
au moins je suis contente voilà et donc
moi je vous le propose fait une
suspension de séance faites un
amendement pour régler la situation et
nous retirons notamment mais pour
l'instant il sera voté
mes chers collègues la question des
transports est vraiment au quotidien
dans la vie de chacun des Franciliens
comme dans tous les territoires et
nous mesurons combien c'est difficile au
quotidien nous mesurons monsieur mise
combien c'est difficile pour le
gouvernement et combien la recherche
d'une solution n'est pas simple philippe
Dominati tout à l'heure a rappelé aussi
l'historique et c'est vrai qu'on demande
à la région Île-de-France de boucler un
budget pour l'idfm avec une situation
qui est figée avec des opérateurs
qu'elle ne maîtrise quasiment pas et
là-dessus je rejoins tout à fait ce qui
a des philippe Dominati mais au bout
d'un moment il y a un budget à faire
approuver il faut trouver un équilibre
pour l'Île-de-France mobilité il faut
assurer la continuité il faut éviter de
devoir réduire l'offre de transport
encore et il faut éviter d'aggraver la
galère au quotidien donc nous sommes
devant ce problème là et nous avons
conscience de l'effort qui serait
demandé aux entreprises ainsi nous
demandons cette réhausse du plafond de
5%. je réinsiste nous é la partie sur 7
et demi et en concertation avec avec la
région nous sommes revenus à un chiffre
qui nous paraît plus raisonnable
évidemment il faut se tourner vers
l'état et Monsieur mais si on propose
cet amendement ici c'est pas pour figer
les choses c'est pour dire simplement
qu'il est important me semble que le
Sénat qui est à l'écoute des territoires
et qui est sur les questions des
transports qui a une voix qui quand même
porte estime qu'il faudra quand même un
effort collectif et que nous sommes
prêts à assumer le fait que oui il
faudra à la fois augmenter le Pass
Navigo et oui il faudra augmenter pour
une part le versement mobilité
nous appelons à l'état la président de
la Région s'est tournée vers les autres
que l'activité locale et vers les
opérateurs pour faire aussi un effort et
ça ne peut être que globalement le
serment terminé en disant que si les
questions de financement du
fonctionnement courant comme de
l'investissement dit de France mobilité
ne sont pas réglées nous allons vers de
sérieux problèmes je vais juste rappeler
que le président du comité d'orientation
a parlé d'un mur d'investissement devant
nous et ça a été rappelé par d'autres
orateurs et on est quasiment qu'il
faudrait doubler l'investissement en
Île-de-France
monsieur le ministre
est-ce que le rapporteur général
souhaiterait intervenir nous allons
écouter chers collègues il serait quand
même préférable que nous arrivions à
voter sur ces amendements avant le
suspension donc
oui je pense que je pense que tout le
monde a envie d'y arriver mais en même
temps on sent bien que le débat mérite
de consacrer un peu de temps il nous est
arrivé dans passé beaucoup parfois pour
des sujets moins lourds de conséquences
moi je veux
à ce stade ramener quelques éléments il
y a effectivement
deux temporalités j'entends et dans la
première temporalité celle peut-être de
quelques semaines je rebondis sur les
propos de philippe Dominati qui dit à
l'endroit du rapporteur général la
conférence des
financeur c'est sympathique mais ça ne
suffit pas et juste après
le sénateur Dominati dit personne ne
veut entamer le dialogue
une conférence des financeurs c'est
justement
en l'imaginant dès maintenant le moyen
d'engager le dialogue avec Messi non non
non
c'est le président cannaire vous savez
très bien que c'est indispensable pour
une raison simple c'est le deuxième
aspect que je voulais rappeler
la dégradation de la situation vient
tout de même à un moment
de la décision au regard de la crise
sanitaire que l'État a imposé et qui a
provoqué des déséquilibres danser
déséquilibres l'étape propose ensuite
des avances remboursables je partage
avec Roger karucci et je pense un
certain d'entre vous finalement on vous
impose une charge
on vous oblige un service on vous en
laisse en tant que comment dirais-je
collectivités organisatrice l'entière
l'entier comment dire l'anti-acharge ça
ne me paraît pas acceptable surtout
lorsque l'on constate que ça provoque
une dégradation continue et tout le
monde l'a dit dégradation du service
mais contentement des usagers
mécontentement des entreprises qui ont
le sentiment que la charge qu'elles
acquitent aujourd'hui ne répond pas aux
besoins de services et de pour le
déplacement de ces salariés de leurs
salariés donc monsieur le ministre je
pense
que plusieurs propositions vous étaient
faites peut-être de
soulager les
îles de France mobilité sur les avances
remboursables mais je pense aussi
effectivement comme Roger carochi l'a
dit que probablement il y aurait une
logique à remplacer tout ou partie de
ces
avances remboursables en dotation
puisque le fait générateur relève de la
responsabilité de l'État
Monsieur Laurent c'est président Laurent
merci monsieur le Président une
explication de votre très courte si nous
ne votons aucun des amendements qui qui
sont qui sont proposés nous allons tout
droit début décembre vers une situation
explosive parce que quand vous ayez
expliqué aux usagers qui subissent cette
situation qu'il faut payer le Pass
Navigo 90 ou 100 euros vous allez voir
vers dans quelle situation nous allons
aller c'est ça c'est la situation vers
laquelle nous allons à cause de
l'irresponsabilité du gouvernement si
nous ne votons aucun des amendements qui
sont proposés ce soir
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
alors moi je considère évidemment qu'en
France on a les niveaux de taxe niveau
d'A prélèvement qui sont les plus élevés
de l'océde c'est une réalité et vouloir
rajouter les taxes sur les entreprises
ça ne fait évidemment pas plaisir pour
reprendre un terme simple cependant
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire à court terme à moyen
long terme mais j'ai un certain nombre
d'idées la conférence pourquoi pas il
faut prendre il faudrait prendre la
mobilité dans son ensemble et pas parler
que des trains des bus il faudrait que
l'autorité puisse aussi avoir un regard
sur les routes mais à court terme
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire l'état ça a
été dit à plusieurs reprises n'a pas
respecté ses engagements et l'État je
parle pas d'où monsieur le ministre mais
je parle de deux premiers ministres qui
étaient deux premiers stressant pas
Pompidou là on a une vision à 30 ans des
transports de l'Île-de-France et
d'ailleurs
là qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire j'étais
invité donc par va récupérer Kress pour
m'y rendre je suis un sénateur du Val
d'Oise et je prends les transports en
commun et les ma voiture de temps en
temps aussi et ce que je peux vous
affirmer moi qui prend la h le RER B je
suis d'accord même c'est même pire ce
que vous dites chers collègue les normes
pour les bêtes ne sont pas respectées
parfois et je pourrais vous faire des
passer des photos ou là on a du mal on
se tient debout on n'a pas besoin de
s'accrocher on est serré donc la
question de faire payer plus les usagers
pour un service qui n'est pas rendu se
pose et la colère monte la colère monte
pour les usagers des transports en
commun mais également pour ceux qui
viennent en véhicule c'est de plus en
plus dur vous qui venez de province
chers collègues les conditions de
transport en Île-de-France se dégradent
année après année tous les cinq ans
c'est de plus en plus long
donc il faudra trouver une solution à
moyen terme il y en existe des solutions
en mettant un peu d'intelligence un peu
d'intelligence artificielle etc donc là
que chacun contribue un petit peu et
bien je pense que c'est la moins
mauvaise enfin la moins mauvaise des
solutions et franchement je vais voterai
c'est pour ça que j'ai signé et vraiment
à mon corps défendant mais je ne vois
pas de solution à court terme que de
faire participer un peu et le Val d'Oise
aussi en tant que collectivité va
financer un petit peu comme merci dans
l'ordre nous commençons par la rendement
le ministre intervient et ensuite nous
votons si vous le voulez bien
il ne peut pas réintervenir monsieur le
ministre je pense que
à monsieur le Président Marseille
il faut qu'on paye on peut même pas
parler
moi je voulais vous dire très rapidement
je partage évidemment le diagnostic qui
a été fait par tous les intervenants ici
mais ce qui met ce qui est le plus
choquant pour moi c'est qu'à défaut de
régler le problème on vient de
diagnostiquer on est en train d'empirer
parce que
cet amendement il fait référence ces
deux amendements ils font référence ils
font référence parce qu'ils divisent
profondément la province avec Paris on a
parlé tout à l'heure mon collègue rue de
lit a parlé de Marseille on s'en moque
on a parlé de Lyon on s'en moque qui se
débrouille on parle de l'île de France
et au sein de l'Île-de-France mon
collègue canela l'a dit tout à l'heure à
la demande de la région à la demande de
la région
on parle d'un certain nombre de de
communes et de département et il y a les
départements qui doivent payer les
villes sont ciblées sont nommées
et puis il y a les autres départements
puis là saisonné c'est pas pourquoi mais
il y a des zones alors à un moment donné
il va falloir regarder qui doit payer
quoi les potentiels fiscaux où sont les
entreprises en Seine-Saint-Denis dans le
Val-de-Marne dans le Val-d'Oise et
pourquoi il y aurait pour la SGP
également
taxation sur les bureaux taxation sur
les parkings qui fait doublette avec
tout ça et pour faire quoi pour faire
des trains qui vont être inaugurés après
les Jeux Olympiques vous parlez d'un
bonheur donc franchement je trouve que
on s'apprête à boiter des choses dans
l'urgence parce qu'on n'a pas été foutu
il faut dire les choses comme elles sont
l'État la Région les départements on n'a
pas été en mesure de régler les
problèmes avant c'est ici qu'on nous
amène les difficultés et on nous dit bah
c'est pas compliqué voilà les cibles il
y a quatre accès là-bas là-bas et puis
on verra après on ne va rien régler et
ceci fait référence parce que maintenant
évidemment et ben on va choisir on va se
servir ici ou là en fonction des
potentiels fiscaux pour savoir qui va
payer quoi Monsieur ben Laroche a
également demandé la parole
parce que c'est normal quand c'est
écoute monsieur le Président en fait
notre groupe ventra les amendements
de Monsieur bouquet Bruyer tabarou et
apokanella parce que effectivement nous
avons conscience que nous sommes devant
une situation exclusive et qu'il est
nécessaire aujourd'hui pour
l'Île-de-France de prendre un certain
nombre de mesures parce que l'État a été
défaillant et l'État continue à être
absent après une défaillance c'est une
absence totale Manifestée aujourd'hui
par le ministre qui qui est
effectivement vraisemblablement très mal
à l'aise sur ce sujet mais je voudrais
quand même comme la diarrhée Marseille
en prologue de son intervention
insister sur la différence qui va se
creuser encore plus de traitement entre
les provinciaux que nous sommes la
promesse que nous représentants la
situation dramatique pour Marseille et
pour la métropole d'exparseille Provost
qui a été mise en avant y compris par le
Président de la République et pour
lequel nous ne faisons rien c'est à dire
que notre assemblée refuse de faire quoi
que ce soit pour la métropole
d'Aix-Marseille Provost de veut dire
quoi que ce soit pour les autres
métropoles dans celle de Lyon refusent
de faire quoi que ce soit pour les
autres collectivités qui en aurait
besoin et qui pourraient le faire
intelligemment et maintenant dit pour
parler nous allons le faire oui nous
allons le faire nous progression nous
sommes solidaires alors nous allons le
faire sur Paris mais excusez-moi
messieurs et les sénateurs et les
sénatrices il est pas logique du tout
dans ce vote que vous n'ayez pas de
cohérence dans vos positions entre la
position la situation parisienne et la
situation du reste de la France
le ministre
merci monsieur le président
madame prima on pourrait vous l'avez
proposé faire une suspension de séance
essayer de régler entre nous le problème
je pense qu'il manquerait un peu de
monde autour de la table la Présidente
de la Région
Île-de-France mobilité le très bon
nouveau président directeur général de
la RATP et puis les représentants
peut-être des entreprises
moi j'ai le droit de l'appeler pour lui
proposer
les représentants des entreprises qui
sont immédiatement très concernés par ce
dont on est en train de parler aussi
quand même on n'est pas et les usagers
vous avez totalement vous avez
totalement raison moi je suis élu
d'Île-de-France je suis parfaitement
conscient des difficultés aujourd'hui
dans les transports collectifs en
Île-de-France vous dire que vous prenez
le métro à la station Malakoff plateau
de Vanves qui est celle en bas de chez
moi les heures de pointe vous en laissez
passer un certain nombre avant d'espérer
pouvoir rentrer je suis parfaitement
conscient de cette situation là et des
problèmes qui sont rencontrés dans les
transports collectifs en Île-de-France
la question c'est de savoir la réponse
qu'on apporte à cette situation ce que
dit le rapport annuel sur les transports
collectifs en Île-de-France de la Cour
des comptes ce qui a été commenté par
Christine lavard qui est un rapport
utile c'est qu'il y a pas de solutions
magiques
c'est qu'il y a pas de solution évidente
ça nécessite qu'on regarde sur le modèle
de financement avec un modèle qui
aujourd'hui quasiment majoritairement
financé par l'impôt des entreprises
qu'on regarde sur un certain nombre de
leviers d'économies qui peuvent exister
sur d'autres sources de financement ce
rapport est une deuxième chose qui me
semble importante je réponds à Monsieur
karucci
je parlais du rapport annuel de la Cour
des comptes qui a été mentionné par
Christine Davard qui dit qu'il n'y a pas
de solution magique il dit une deuxième
chose que j'ai entendu monsieur caoutchi
que vous disiez on a l'impression que
l'État est ailleurs d'autres ont dit
l'état fuis ces responsabilités ce
rapport annuel de la Cour des comptes
non l'État est ailleurs j'ai noté ce
rapport annuel de la Cour des comptes il
dit une phrase il y a eu ces trois
dernières années une intervention
massive et inconditionnelle de l'État
pour Île-de-France mobilité
inconditionnel et massive
inconditionnel et massif c'est la Cour
des comptes c'est la Cour des comptes
écoutez écoutez je vous entends
abondamment vous appuyez sur les
rapports de la Cour des comptes sur un
certain nombre d'arguments que vous
déployez vis-à-vis du gouvernement je
cite la Cour des comptes il y a une
intervention massive et inconditionnelle
de l'État pour Île-de-France mobilité 2
milliards d'euros pendant la crise covid
de soutien à Île-de-France mobilité
je peux aller au bout de mon de mon
propos si vous le si vous le souhaitez
la question qui est posée ici avec ses
amendements c'est si on considère que le
problème se règle en augmentant les
impôts des entreprises
nous avons souffrait que ce soit notre
position la conviction qu'il ne faut pas
augmenter les impôts de production mais
qu'il faut les baisser
vous avez fait le choix dans l'examen
antérieur de ce texte de revenir sur la
suppression de la CVAE que nous
proposons moi je le dis simplement ne
souhaiterions pas que ce texte qui est
entré avec une baisse de 4 milliards
d'euros d'impôts de production pour les
entreprises sortent avec une hausse d'un
milliard d'euros des impôts de
production pour les entreprises on a
abondamment commenté le fait que le
versement mobilité est versé par les
entreprises qu'il a été très dynamique
cette année cette année le versement
mobilité il augmente de 800 millions
d'euros au niveau national on passe les
10 milliards d'euros c'est 200 millions
d'euros de plus pour Île-de-France
mobilité pourquoi est-ce que le
versement mobilité augmente
parce que la masse salariale augmente
pourquoi est-ce que la masse salariale
augmente parce que les entreprises
embauchent pourquoi les entreprises
embauchent parce que nous baissons les
impôts et la pression fiscale et donc
moi j'entends les solutions de
j'entends les solutions qui me semblent
de court terme de dire on va augmenter
les impôts de production va augmenter le
versement mobilité pour financer
Île de France mobilité
ça apportera peut-être ça apportera
peut-être des ressources à court terme
mais qu'est-ce qui va se passer ensuite
ben il y aura moins d'emploi et donc il
y aura moins de ma salariale et donc il
y aura moins de recettes pour le
versement mobilité
j'ai le droit de donner mes arguments
donc moi ce que je vous ai dit on n'est
pas ici on n'est pas ici on n'est pas
ici en débat sur la mission transport de
la partie de duplf n'est pas au conseil
régional de France on n'est pas dans les
instances où ce sujet-là est discuté je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il était
porté par la première ministre elle-même
par mon collègue Christophe Béchu par
mon collègue Clément Beaune en charge
des transports monsieur carochi vous
parliez des avances remboursables du
fait que j'aurai une position fermée à
la question des avances remboursables a
été posée tout à l'heure par le
rapporteur général vous n'avez pas
entendu derrière
me lever en disant je ne veux pas
entendre parler de ce sujet là je ne
veux pas en discuter
vous ne m'avez pas entendu dire cela moi
ce que je dis c'est qu'il y a un travail
qui se poursuit avec la première
ministre avec les ministres concernés
pour regarder toutes les solutions qui
sont possibles et qui sont envisageables
mais je le dis gardons-nous des
solutions simpliste parce que la réalité
c'est que si on dit il faut que tout ça
ça se mette sur le dos de l'État avec la
transformation d'avance remboursable
j'ai entendu monsieur salvoli faire
référence et j'ai très heureux de
l'entendre aux agences de notation et à
Moïse sur l'importance de suivre ce que
nous disent les agences de notation
est-ce que nous dit mooedies vous avez
dit que c'était très important la
réalité je vous ai peut-être pas le
droit de le dire mais vous l'avez dit la
réalité c'est que si nous ne maintenons
pas à une trajectoire responsable des
finances publiques
on aura une dégradation de notre note
par ces mêmes agences de notation et qui
le subira les régions dans la note
seront dégradées aussi puisque aucune
région ne peut avoir une note meilleure
que l'État français et donc la réalité
c'est que c'est pas non plus c'est pas
non plus une solution magique non mais
je le dis j'essaye j'essaye d'expliquer
notre position il n'y a pas de solutions
magiques il ne peut avoir une multitude
de solutions les discussions vont se
poursuivre au niveau de la première
ministre et des ministres concernés mais
moi je le dis nous ne souhaitons pas
qu'un projet de loi de finance qui est
entré dans cette chambre avec une baisse
d'un peu de production de 4 milliards
d'euros sortent avec une hausse d'un pot
de production d'un milliard d'euros
parce que la réalité c'est que les
victimes ça serait nos entreprises et
infiner les salariés y compris de ceux
des régions qu'on veut protéger
alors
sur l'amendement 840 déposée par le
groupe CRCE j'ai une demande de scrutin
public qui va être procédé il va être
procédé de ce que tu es un public dans
les conditions fixées par le règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
sur de la Commission et du gouvernement
ne demande plus à voter scrutin avec
l'eau
votant 343
exprimé 329 pour l'amendement 91 contre
238 il n'est pas adopté
nous votons ensuite sur l'amendement de
Monsieur Breuillet qui est pour
qui est contre
y a-t-il des abstentions
n'est pas adoptée sur l'amendement 715
de Monsieur Tabaro et collègues nous
avons une demande de scrutin public
déposé par le groupe
UC sur les deux amendements puisqu'ils
sont identiques de Monsieur Tabaro de
Monsieur capo canelas la ville de la
Commission et la vie du Gouvernement est
défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
alors le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin
votant 343
exprimez 329 pour l'amendement 121
contre 208 ils ne sont pas adoptés
nous continuons avec l'amendement 927 de
Monsieur Dominati qui à la parole
merci monsieur le président